Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Ich bin Asthen Ersten auf dieser Station tätig und heute für Sie so ständig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengeschritt durchführen.
Sie sind damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, mir ist wichtig, dass jemand nach mir guckt und dass mir jemand hilft.
Mir geht es nämlich nicht gut.
Ich würde erst einmal ein paar Fragen zur Ihrer Person fragen.
Wie heißt du?
Ich heiße Willi Jege und Willi mit Y am Ende.
Können Sie bitte Ihren und Vornamen buchen, bitte?
Der Familienname ist Jege, J-A-U-N-G-E-R, Jege.
Und der Vorname ist Willi, W-I-L-L-Y.
Ja, Flaschstipp, oder?
Ja, ja.
Willi ist ein Männername.
Ja, okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin noch 57 Jahre, aber im Mai werde ich 58.
Ja, wann ist sie genau geworden?
Am 16. Mai 65.
Wie groß wird sie?
Oh, ich bin 1,74 m und wiege 70 kg.
Herr Jege, was für mich für mich Verden haben Sie?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe mit einmal solche heftigen Schmerzen beim Schlucken.
Das geht schon eine ganze Weile.
Und das wird aber immer schlimmer.
Ich merke, dass es mir gar nicht gut geht.
Und jetzt, beim Essen hat es mir schon immer weh getan,
oder jetzt schon wochenlang.
Aber jetzt ist das selbst, wenn ich ein Schluck Wasser trinke,
dass ich das Gefühl habe, das tut mir so im Hals weh
und beziehungsweise eigentlich noch so ein bisschen tiefer.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe so ein Klos im Hals.
Das ist ein ganz unangenehm.
Und dann ist mir jetzt auch noch etwas aufgefallen.
Das hat mich ganz unruhig gemacht.
Ich habe das schon mal gehört, dass das nicht gut ist.
Ich hatte mehrfach so ganz dunklen Stuhlgang.
Und jetzt muss ich aber doch mal zügig in die Klinik gehen.
Das wissen Sie, mein Hausarzt hat Urlaub über diese Tage jetzt.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, ich komme jetzt einfach mal zu Ihnen hier ins Krankenhaus.
Ja, Sie haben sehr gut gemacht, dass Sie ins Krankenhaus gekommen sind.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schluckschweißen?
Schluckgeschweißen.
Ja, also ich würde sagen,
dass das so vor drei Wochen ungefähr angefangen hat.
Aber das wird immer schlechter.
Ja, können Sie bitte beschreiben, wie diese Schmelzen aufgetreten sind?
Ja, ich habe das gemerkt.
Ich habe das gemerkt beim Essen.
Dann habe ich erst gedacht, hast du nicht gut gekaut.
Und habe dann extra vorsichtig gegessen und immer ganz lange gekaut.
Und auch dafür gesorgt, dass ich nicht so trockenes Essen hatte.
Und dann habe ich aber gemerkt, dass es eigentlich immer beim Essen wehtut.
Ja, also wenn ich super gegessen habe oder Gemüse oder sowas,
das gekocht ist, das ging.
Aber bei Brot zum Beispiel, das wollte überhaupt nicht runterrutschen.
Und beim Trinken ging es eigentlich immer.
Und jetzt mit einmal ist es selbst, wenn ich klares Wassertrinker oder abgedacht habe,
das Gefühl, das wehtut im Hals.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder Haarschmerzen?
Haarschmerzen, nein.
Haarschmerzen, Haarschmerzen.
Haarschmerzen, ja, ja.
Ja, ja, es tut eigentlich etwas tiefer als der Hals.
Nicht direkt hier oben, sondern ein bisschen tiefer.
So hier oben tut es weh überwiegend.
Können Sie diese Sämtome beschreiben, wie tut es weh?
Gibt es Druckgefühl?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe so einen Klo im Hals.
Und es brennt auch irgendwie ein bisschen.
Ja.
Manchmal muss ich auch aufstoßen.
Schützt haben diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus, oder?
Ja, ich habe sie nun hinterher dann.
Nein, eigentlich ist das hier so oben, in dem oberen Brustbereich
und im unteren Halsbereich.
Aber sonst irgendwie so in den Arm oder so,
oder in den Bauchstreis ist nicht aus.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Dunkelstür haben.
Können Sie bitte diese Stürme beschreiben?
Wie ist das?
Ja, das war eigentlich fast normaler Sturlgang,
vielleicht ein bisschen weicher als normal.
Und der sah aber ganz dunkel aus, also ganz merkwürdig.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, das habe ich schon mal gelesen,
dass das kein gutes Zeichen ist.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, ich gehe doch mal lieber zum Arzt.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Dunkelstür?
Ja, das war jetzt erst die letzten Tage,
vorgestern und gestern.
Ja, vorgestern.
Okay.
Und wissen Sie, was ganz gemein ist, was ganz unangenehm ist?
Ich habe das Gefühl, mir läuft die ganze Zeit die Spucke.
Also ich muss ständig runterschlucken
und dabei tut das Schlucken doch so weh.
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, die ganze Zeit produziert
und ich habe jetzt noch 9 Speiche.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie einen Schmack an den Blut?
Witteren Geschmack?
Das ist mir jetzt nicht so aufgefallen, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fibre?
Boah, habe ich nicht gemessen, weiß ich nicht,
kann ich Ihnen echt nicht sagen.
Ich habe nicht gemessen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schüttelfraus nach Schweiß?
Naja, ich schwitze nicht in der Nacht,
aber ich schlafe schlecht, das stimmt ja.
Ja, sie haben Schlafschtöne.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nicht so richtig übel, ist mir eigentlich nicht.
Ja, ja, so dieses mit der Spucke, das ist so ja,
als ob ein bisschen schlecht ist,
aber mir schmeckt das Essen schon eigentlich
jetzt ziemlich lange nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie manchmal,
ich habe richtig verstanden.
Noch mal bitte.
Haben Sie erbrieren,
manchmal nacken.
Nein, nein, nein,
manchmal am Abend habe,
wenn ich im Bett liege,
dass ich so aufstoßen muss.
Oder auch manchmal direkt nach dem Essen.
Okay.
Haben Sie verandert,
verandert in der Wasserlastung bemerkt,
in der Neste Zeit?
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlastung?
Eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, schwindelig würde ich nicht sagen.
Ja, wusstet man Sie?
Ja, so ein bisschen Hustenreiz habe ich vor allem morgens,
habe ich das.
Und manchmal auch,
wenn dann dieses Aufstoßen kommt,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, ich müsste hüsten.
Ist der Husten-Türkung
oder mit dem Ausflug?
Da kommt eigentlich nichts raus, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der Neste Zeit ab oder so genommen?
Da sagen Sie was, ja, tatsächlich.
Ich habe ein bisschen Gewicht abgenommen.
Ich habe das gemerkt, meine Hosen waren mit einmal so weit.
Und dann habe ich mich mal auf die Waage gestellt.
Und dann habe ich tatsächlich 3 kg abgenommen, ja.
Ja, in drei Wochen haben Sie 3 kg abgenommen, oder?
Ja, ich wieg mich ja nicht so oft, aber
vielleicht habe ich mich zuletzt vor 5, 6 Wochen gewogen,
aber jedenfalls ist mir das jetzt aufgefallen,
dass alle Klamotten weit sind.
Und dann habe ich mich mal wieder nach langer Zeit gewogen.
Und da habe ich gesehen, dass ich 3 kg wirklich abgenommen habe.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Da habe ich schon gesagt, es schmeckt mir nicht besonders.
Ich habe es schon gesagt, es schmeckt mir nicht besonders.
Aber ich bin natürlich auch alleine.
Meine Frau lebt nicht mehr.
Und ja, dann einfach macht es keinen Spaß,
etwas zu kochen oder so.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie schrafen nicht so gut.
Schrafen Sie wegen Aufstoßen nicht gut, oder?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich habe gesagt, Sie schrafen nicht so gut.
Ich habe gesagt, Sie schrafen nicht so gut, oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das der Grund ist.
Aber insgesamt habe ich das Gefühl,
ich bin ein bisschen unruhig.
Manchmal fehlt mir dann noch ein extra Schnaps,
oder so, dass ich vielleicht besser schlafen könnte.
Okay. Können Sie flach legen?
Ohne Kissen?
Ne, ohne Kissen geht ja gar nicht.
Also, 1, 2 Kissen habe ich wohl, ja.
Ja, 1, 2 Kissen.
Haben Sie heiß oder halb Klopfen?
Herdklopfen habe ich nicht, nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder ist das Beobägung,
Beide-Reppe-Steigen?
Ja, also Atemnot nicht.
Ich merke, dass ich schlapp bin.
Ich bin zum Einkaufen gegangen oder nach der Arbeit nach Hause gelaufen bin.
Zügig.
Merke ich, dass ich jetzt deutlich langsamer bin.
Und ja, dass ich, dass ich kao bin, wenn ich nach Hause komme.
Ja, oder auch wenn ich die Treppe hoch gelaufen bin.
Dass ich dann denke, boah, das ist aber gut, dass ich da bin.
Also, das ist nicht direkt, dass ich keine Luft kriege oder so.
Aber, boah, ich merke, dass das anstrengend ist.
Okay, ich habe Verstande.
Haben Sie Allergie gegen die Treppe?
Ja, ich habe eine Allergie auf Gräser und auf Mehl.
Und da kriege ich also so Schnupfen und rote Augen.
Das kann ich nicht vertragen.
Und was ich tatsächlich auch nicht vertrage,
hat man mal festgestellt, die Klophenack kann ich nicht nehmen.
Ja, ja, war es die Allergie, die Sie auf die Klophenack?
Ja, da habe ich auch so ein rotes Gesicht bekommen.
Und das war irgendwie nicht gut.
Ja, okay.
Weiten Sie irgendwelche Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie Bluthochdrück?
Hab ich schon lange Diabetes.
Wissen Sie, seit 15 Jahren habe ich schon Diabetes.
Also eigentlich ja schon relativ früh bekommen.
Und vor zwei Wochen ist der mal so ein bisschen durcheinander geraten.
Aber dann war ich beim Arzt und dann haben wir noch mal geguckt.
Und dann ist das alles wieder eingestellt.
Was war die HWI-Site?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Aber ist alles in Ordnung?
Jetzt war das alles wieder in Ordnung, ja.
Was nehmen Sie? Sind Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich hatte so ein Steinbeutel am linken Ellenbogen.
Der ist operiert worden.
Das ist aber schon lange her.
Ja, warum wurde er so?
Das war vor, lassen Sie mich überlegen, das muss so vor zwölf Jahren gewesen sein.
Ja, vor zwölf Jahren.
Ja, okay.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente?
Was nehmen Sie?
Ja, ich nehme Ikandra.
Wie viel Begrüßung?
Das steht drauf 50.000.
Da nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Ja, okay. Nehmen Sie noch?
Ne, sonst nehme ich nichts.
Okay.
Sie haben die Vorstand geïft?
Ja, ja, sicher. Klar.
Ich habe viel Kontakt.
Ich arbeite als Zerrkner, da trifft man viele Leute.
Da bin ich natürlich gegen Corona dreimal geimpft.
Okay, das war sehr gut.
Waren Sie idealistisch im Ausland?
Im Ausland? Nein, nein, ich war ganz holschlich.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Jaeger?
Ja.
Also, das muss ich ja zugeben.
Ich rauche ordentlich ein Päckchen am Tag.
Rauche ich schon, ja.
Ja, seit wann rauchen Sie?
Ungefähr wie viele Jahre?
Oh, ich würde mal so sagen, seit ich Mitte 20 bin so.
Okay, Mitte 20?
Ja, ungefähr 30 Jahre, seit 30 Jahren.
Kann man sagen, ja.
Okay.
Trinken Sie ein Alkohol?
Ja, also ich trink wohl mal ein Bier abends.
Das trinke ich ziemlich regelmäßig, auch mal zwei.
Und am Wochenende, oder ja, wenn ich das Gefühl habe,
dass mir Essen nicht so gut bekommen ist,
dann trinke ich auch mal ein Gläschen Schnaps,
aber nicht jeden Tag.
Okay, aber auch ne Handel.
Okay, haben Sie Kontakt mit Droge?
Mit Drogen?
Nein, wirklich nicht.
Okay, leben Ihre Alkohol noch?
Ach nein, nein, nein.
Also mein Vater lebt noch, aber meine Mutter,
die ist ja nicht alt geworden.
Die hatte Darmkrebs.
Und da ist sie gestorben, da war sie 74 Jahre alt.
Ja, ich war 74.
Ja, dann habe ich sie schon.
Danke.
Leider hat Ihr Vater einen Chronischen Erkrankung.
Nein, der hat einen Magengeschwür.
Und da hat er manchmal ein bisschen Probleme,
da muss er mit dem Essen aufpassen.
Aber der ist ja jetzt auch schon nicht mehr so jung,
der kommt aber ganz gut zurecht eigentlich.
Okay, sehr gut.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe nicht Geschwister.
Okay, was machen Sie, wer ist die?
Ja, ich arbeite als Fördner.
Was, wie tickt es?
In einer großen Firma.
Ich sitze am Empfang, also an der Porte.
Und lasst mir von den Leuten die Ausweise zeigen,
wenn jemand in den Sicherheitsbereich geht
und ansonsten melde ich Gäste an, wenn jemand kommt
und guckt, dass die abgeholt werden und so was.
Okay, okay.
Sie ist verheiratet?
Meine Frau ist gestorben, ich bin verwirrt.
Ich bin beide.
Wann gestorben und vorhin gestorben?
Ach, ich bin es.
Ja, das ist gar nicht so richtig klar gewesen,
dass die Ursache war, wahrscheinlich hat sie eine schwere Infektion gehabt.
Und das ist jetzt aber schon auch einige Jahre her.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder gehabt.
Sind sie gesund?
Die sind gesund, ja.
Ja, gut sei da.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Nein, also nicht wirklich.
Und zurzeit könnte ich das auch wirklich nicht.
Also ich bin manchmal am Wochenende Fahrrad gefahren
oder früher habe ich schon ein bisschen mehr gemacht,
aber jetzt letzter Zeit eigentlich kein Sport.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie sich auf der Arbeit oder im Piraten?
Nein, würde ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Ich denke mal, das läuft alles so.
Ich habe schon lange gemacht, dass wir schon so lange da kennt man sich aus,
da erlebt man eigentlich keine Überraschungen mehr.
Okay.
Ich möchte noch einige Fragen stellen.
Haben Sie ihr nicht beschweren im Führer?
Hatte ich schon mal solche Beschwerden, nee, das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Also ich hatte natürlich, hat man irgendwann mal so Halsschmerzen,
aber das fühlt sich anders an.
Ja, Halsschmerzen sind ja meistens hier oben so direkt am Anfang vom Hals,
aber das sitzt viel tiefer eigentlich.
Und auch dieses Gefühl, dass man so ein Kloß im Hals hat,
dass man nicht gut schlucken kann, das habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Ja, sie wird Ihnen schon einmal magisch spiegelugt durchgeführt
oder da im Spiegelug?
Nee, da bin ich ein bisschen nachlässig.
Da habe ich ein bisschen Angst davor gehabt
und dann habe ich das nicht gemacht.
Okay.
Haben Sie geschwollene Knöpfe klämpft und auf dem Hals
oder irgendwo in Kerlpark bemerkt?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, aber ich taste da ja auch nicht rum.
Okay.
Okay. Ich habe meine Fragen gestellt.
Möchte Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich möchte natürlich wissen, dass man dagegen machen kann.
Muss ich jetzt hier im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Können Sie mir das erklären, warum ist der Stuhlgang so komisch-schwarz?
Ja, ich kann jeden Moment noch nicht ein Genadialgnose sagen.
Ich möchte mich ein paar Untersuchungen belegen.
Sie müssen bei uns für weitere Untersuchungen belegen.
Ich möchte erst einmal körperliche Untersuchungen,
Blutuntersuchungen und Apparativtieren machen.
Was machen Sie da?
Apparativtieren, das ist eine Wahlfahrerin mit dem Hilfegerät durchgeführt,
wie Roboruntersuchungen, Ultraschall.
Das tut aber nicht weh, ne?
Ja, machen Sie keine Sorgen, Sie sind im guten Herden.
Ja, und unser Team hat große Erfahrungen damit.
Wir müssen erst einmal die Untersuchungsergebnisse abwarten.
Je nachdem ich Ergebnisse habe, komme ich zu Ihnen zurück
und erkele Ihnen alles Schritt by Schritt.
Das ist gut. Das klingt gut.
Nehmen Sie Platz?
Ich warte dann hier.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Ich habe zwei Fragen.
Ein ist von meinem Kollegen schon geschrieben.
Haben Sie Sudbrennen?
Das hat eigentlich nicht so richtig gesagt.
Er hat Aufstoßen, aber richtig Sudbrennen.
Dass da so Mageninhalt hochkommt, sagt er eigentlich nicht.
Mein zweiter Frage.
Mein zweiter ist vom Verdachtab.
Haben Sie Heisigkeit?
Ich habe Sie sehr gut verstehen, aber haben Sie eine Stimplendeme?
Ist nicht geschildert, könnte aber natürlich sein.
Ja, ich glaube, es muss etwas sein.
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein bisschen heiser.
Das kann ich aber schlecht imitieren.
Kein Problem.
Haben Sie die Becherung früher?
Nein, für den habe ich überrascht.
So etwas hatte er noch nicht vorher.
Das hat er aber auch schon gefragt.
Gibt es ihm schon Bullock?
Er hat nur gesehen, dass der Stuhl dunkel ist.
Das war für ihn der Auslöser, dass er gesagt hat,
jetzt muss ich aber da doch mal hingehen.
Ich habe das schon mal gehört, dass es nicht gut ist, wenn der Stuhl ganz schwarz ist.
Können wir als Gechübchen anfangen?
Ich denke, keine Fragen gestärkt.
Sind Sie schon so weit?
Oder brauchen Sie noch ein paar Minuten?
Ja, okay.
Hallo, guten Abend Oberleister.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Sie seid ja schon so weit.
Ich bin schon so weit.
Ich habe das schon gesagt.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ja natürlich, erzählst du, wen haben Sie gesehen?
Ja, ich berichte über den Willy Jäger.
Er ist 47 Jahre, geboren am 18.5.1985.
Er hat sich bei uns seit drei Wochen
bei der Schulungstörung
seit 3 Wochen vorgestellt.
Er klagt über die Schulungstörung
und die Schulungstörung.
auf Touristik.
Auch auf Touristik?
Ja.
Er klagt über die Globusgefühl,
Er gab sie gewiss Abnahme 3 Programme in 5 oder 6 Wochen in Appetenz und Schlafstörungen.
Er war in Urlau und deswegen ist er uns gekommen.
Er hat allergisch auf Gräser Milchprodukte und die Gröffenag.
Er ist vollständig geimpft auf den Corona.
Er ist mit 74 Jahren am Kolonkarsnum gestorben.
Er ist mit ein paar Jahren wegen der Selbstgeschwürzung gestorben.
Er ist sehr gesund und hat nichts zu tun.
Er ist sehr alt.
bisher wurden ihnen keine Endoskopie, keine Colonoskopie durchgeführt.
Ja, bis hier die an amnästischen Angaben dort am ehesten eine Zofagus-Kars-Nome hin.
Was wäre differential diat noch, ist noch möglich? Was könnte es sein?
Was könnte es sein? Differenzialdiat Luigi?
Shute rumba, Zofagus Shute rumba, nee nein, nee...
Shute rumba, ich satu Gröse, färgroose rumba...
Ja, schute rumba.
Das hat eine größerte Luftknopfen hat.
Was könnte es noch sein, wenn es nicht der größere Luftknopfen ist?
Ja, Ösophage ist die Welt.
Ja, und ich habe noch zwei Sachen auf meinem Zettel stehen.
Es könnte ein Lungenkartzenomen sein mit der Ösophagos-Beteiligung.
Dann habe ich hier noch stehen eine Achalasi.
Achalasi.
Das ist eine Bewegungsstörung, praktisch eine Mutilitätsstörung in der Speiserer.
Ja, was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Ich möchte erst einmal den Körperlisch und die Sterretteruntersuchung untersuchen.
Ich taste dann das erst einmal auf, ich suche einen Verrindungsmotor oder ganze Körper.
Dann höre ich Lungen und Herz auf und ich schaue auch Brasshauten.
Ich suche einen Anämiseitschirm.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und die Patient hat Medina beschreiben, deswegen mache ich digitale Rectaluntersuchung.
Sehr gut, ja, sehr gut.
Was machen Sie lau-wo technisch?
Ja, ich wollte Blutbild, CRP, Blutzucker, HBA1, HBA1, Elektrolyt, Sodium, Calium, Calcium.
Und? Was auch noch wichtig?
Nierenweite, Leberweite.
Was ist das andere? Sie wollten nach der Animikung?
Ja, Animik, Serity, oder?
Ja, oder überhaupt den HB-Wert, nicht nur HBA1c, sondern auch den HB-Wert.
Ich meine Blutbild, ja, da haben Sie es drin, Blutgestark.
Ja, Blutbild, ja, Blutgestark.
Ich habe das Blutbild, Leberweite, Schmuckwerte, Bechtinle.
Gut, wie geht es weiter?
Was machen Sie noch?
Ich schreibe jetzt mal, ich schreibe jetzt mal, ich schreibe jetzt mal,
und mag ich, ja, da ist es besser, ich schreibe jetzt mal.
Mhm, gut.
Und gegebenenfalls, City, City, Tolax, Hass.
Ja, falls da wirklich irgendwas ist, dass man da nochmal genauer guckt, genau.
Und macht es Sinn? Ich habe keine Ahnung, das ist wirklich eine Frage.
Macht es Sinn, diese Gegend sonografisch zu untersuchen?
Hals und Wurstbereich?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man da was sehen kann.
Ja, im Haarssonographie untersuchen wir erstmal Schiebküfe,
und die Leftnoten, ein superglöberes, deine Grüße,
und das mal.
Genau, das könnte man gut sehen, ja.
Gut, dann, seien Sie doch so nett, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden
über den Patienten, über den Herrn Jäger, informieren Sie mich,
was bei Ihren Ergebnissen rausgekommen ist.
Was machen Sie denn, wenn sich Ihre Diagnose bestätigt?
Wie sehe denn die Therapie aus?
Ja, ich mache ja einfach, Sie das zu.
Ja, okay.
Ich nehme, ich lege einen Zugang an.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Ja, ich messe mit einem Teilkalimeter.
Ich glaube, die Patienten braucht Schlüssigkeit soviel.
Sie trinken nicht so genau.
Ja, ja, ja, ist ein Mann.
Ja.
Ja, es gibt Schlüssigkeit.
Wenn Sie die Anämie erhalten,
nehmen Sie eine Schwergrat, eine Bluttransfusion?
Genau, genau.
Wie kommt es, wie kommt es, war eine Prüferfrage,
wie kommt es zur Melena, wenn er tatsächlich
ein Usufaguskarzinom hat?
Was ist dann der Grund für den schwarzen Stuhl?
Ja, Melena deutet, das, das ist,
das ist das, das ist das, das ist das,
das ist das, das ist das, das ist das.
Genau, genau, ja.
Genau, genau.
Gut.
Ja, wie gesagt, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Lauffenden,
was draus geworden ist.
Alles gut, ja.
Ich habe ein bisschen Manöverkritik.
Zum Ersten kann ich sagen, Ihre Anamnese fand ich super.
Die war wirklich top, sehr schlüssig.
Und das Einzige, was mich da ein bisschen gestört hat,
alle, die schon länger zuhören bei diesen Anamnesen,
kennen meine Aversion,
haben immer wieder gefragt, haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie,
haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie, ja.
Also versuchen Sie da ein bisschen
Variation reinzubringen, ja.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, das haben Sie bemerkt.
Okay.
Also, so, so, dass man, dass man nicht immer die ganze,
ist Ihnen aufgefallen, ja.
Also, dass man nicht immer haben Sie gefragt, ja.
Gibt es, kann man vielleicht auch manchmal fragen, ja.
So, das war die eine Geschichte.
Dann habe ich in der, in dem Bericht,
in Ihrem Bericht an die Kollegen,
dann habe ich das Gefühl gehabt,
dass wir ein bisschen Probleme mit den Zahlen haben.
Der Patient ist ja Jahrgang 65 und 57 Jahre alt.
Und wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe, haben Sie gesagt,
er ist 47 Jahre alt und Jahrgang 84.
Das passt nicht zusammen, ja.
Also, wenn er, wenn er,
wenn er Jahrgang 84 wäre, ja, dann wäre er jetzt 39.
Ja, ich habe 57 geschrieben, aber ich habe 57.
Ja, genau.
57, also er ist 57 Jahre alt, Jahrgang 65.
Okay.
Dann haben wir Augenblick,
wir haben 35 Jahre im alten Jahrhundert
und im neuen Jahrhundert 23 Jahre, das passt.
Dann sind es, also er wird jetzt demnächst 58, ne.
Hat er ja auch gesagt, er hat im Mai Geburtstag
und dann wird er 58.
Gut, dann ist mir ein richtiger Hörfehler aufgefallen.
Er hat eine Gräser- und Mehlallergie.
Nicht Milch, sondern Mehl.
Mehl.
Ja, und dann ist mir noch eine Sache aufgefallen.
Das ist auch etwas, was ganz oft, ich habe das schon oft vergessen zu sagen.
Es fällt mir aber immer wieder ein und auf.
Haben Sie Kontakt zu den Drogen?
Da sagt man keinen Artikel.
Und also Sie haben jetzt auch noch die,
Sie haben irgendwie zu die Drogen, oder die Drogen,
haben Sie die Drogenkonsum, oder so, ganz minus.
Mit Drogen.
Also, ja.
Also, wenn man so fragt, macht man keinen Artikel,
nimmt man keinen Artikel.
Also, Sie sagen ja auch trinken Sie Alkohol, raufen Sie,
oder konsumieren Sie Tabak, haben Sie Kontakt zu Drogen.
Kein Artikel.
Das war das andere.
Ja, dann haben wir in der, bei der Anamnäsenschilderung,
da habe ich eigentlich immer drauf gewartet,
auf das große Zauberwort, der Patient benutzt das natürlich nicht.
Aber Sie müssen es benutzen,
dass er retro-sternale Schmerzen hat.
Ja, er hat ja gesagt, es ist nicht hier oben im Halt,
sondern weiter unten.
Der Patient kennt den Fachbegriff nicht.
Ja, aber Sie müssen den kennen.
Ja, also er hat retro-sternale Schmerzen
und eigentlich weniger richtige Halsschmerzen.
Schön haben Sie geschildert dieses Klosgefühl, dieses Globusgefühl.
Ja.
Ja, beim Ikandra war ich mir jetzt auch nicht sicher,
da manche ich auch, dass mir die Zahlen falsch haben.
Was haben Sie sich aufgeschrieben?
Ikandra, welche Dosierung?
Ich habe es für Sie so, 100.
Ja, und er hat gesagt, 50.000, mein ich, hätte er gesagt.
Steht jetzt zumindest bei mir, ich habe keine Ahnung,
dass das für ein Zeug ist.
Ja, gut, wir auch immer.
Also, bei Zahlen aufpassen wirklich.
So, und sonst bin ich aber sehr zurück gewesen.
Also, wie gesagt, sprachlich war die Anamnese wirklich richtig supergut
und der Bericht war ein bisschen weniger gut, sage ich mal.
Aber ich glaube, Sie brauchen ein bisschen mehr Zeit,
um Ihre Sachen zu formulieren.
Kann das sein?
Ja.
Sie sprechen ja sehr gut flüssig Deutsch.
Ja, jetzt müssen Sie nur noch genau diese Alltagssprache
anwenden auch für das Gespräch mit dem Kollegen.
Aber ich denke mal, Sie beherrschen die Sprache eigentlich.
Wenn Sie ein bisschen Zeit haben, ein bisschen Ruhe zur Vorbereitung,
dann könnte das doch gut klappen.
Ja?